[musique]
Alex Pouchkov, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Euh merci de venir interagir sur une
chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle Syerview.
On est sur internet, nous sommes en
live, en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Euh Alexis ou bien Alexe en russe
Pushkov, je suis euh membre du Sénat à
la chambre supérieure du Parlement
russe. Pendant 5 ans euh j'ai été
président de la commission des affaires
euh internationales
euh dans la chambre inférieure, la Duma.
Euh je suis depuis 2 ans au Sénat et je
suis président de la commission pour les
informations et les médias.
Vous avez un background de journalistes,
[raclement de gorge] de diplomates,
d'historiens et ensuite de journaliste.
C'est vrai.
Vous avez un show télé ?
Oui, j'ai un show télé qui dure depuis
20 ans déjà. Il a commencé, je l'ai
lancé en 1998
et il a survécu
enfin trois présidents.
Euh il a survécu un grand changement en
Russie qui s'est opéré dans les années
2000.
Il est toujours numéro 1 par la côte de
popularité sur la chaîne où il est
diffusé. C'est la 3è chaîne de la
télévision nationale qui s'appelle TV
Centre.
Euh et c'est un programme qui est devenu
un élément, je dirais indispensable de
l'information politique et surtout de
l'analyse politique à la télévision
russe. Donc j'ai une audience très
stable euh très importante et très
qualifiée. Ce sont des gens qui
s'intéressent à la politique, ce sont
des professionnels mais aussi des
citoyens qui font autre chose mais qui
pensent que la politique est importante
et qu'il faut
qu'il faut y comprendre mieux. Euh et
donc c'est mon audience
et elle ne change pas, elle est elle
grimpe un peu parfois mais elle ne
descend jamais.
On a on a intitulé euh notre interview
le le futur du monde, la nouvelle menace
russe.
Pourquoi on parle de cette menace russe
surtout en Occident ?
Je pense que l'Occident est en crise de
nerf.
Et cette crise de nerf est produite par
le changement des
des rapports de force à l'échelle
internationale.
C'est que l'Occident
s'est accoutumé de se voir un leader
incontesté du monde contemporain. Et
c'était le cas pendant
plusieurs centenaires d'ailleurs. Mais
le problème c'est que le monde change.
Le monde change. Et quand en 1991, un
philosophe américain Francis Fukuyama a
fait un article provocateur
sur la fin.
Oui, il a posé. Oui, la fin de
l'histoire
et tout le monde s'est mis à réfléchir.
Est-ce que la fin de l'histoire est
possible ? Est-ce que ça peut arriver ?
Est-ce que un modèle politique, social
et économique peut s'établir pour des
centenaires à venir ? Et on est venu à
la conclusion, je pense que c'est un
consensus international que l'histoire
ne finit jamais et que un modèle peut
exister pendant un certain bout de temps
et puis il s'effondre et il y a quelque
chose qui vient à sa place. Écoutez, le
l'Empire romain, il se considérait
éternel. Il a duré 500 ans. C'est tout
de même important. Je pense que le
modèle néolibéral ne durera pas jusqu'à
500 ans.
Parlons du modèle néolibéral américain.
Vous le définissiez comme une religion.
Il a commencé comme un modèle de
fonctionnement économique. Puis
Margarette Tetcher a prononcé cette
cette phrase fameuse, il faut pas
seulement changer l'économie, il faut
changer l'esprit de l'homme et donc d'en
faire un consommateur, un homme qui va
consommer et ça va faire bouger et
marcher l'économie de marcher
éternellement comme une perpétu mobilée.
Et je pense que euh l'esprit euh l'âme
de beaucoup de citoyens du monde a été
changé par la propagande de
consommation. C'est ce qu'on appelle
chez nous en Russie la culture chopard,
quand les gens veulent toujours plus et
toujours plus euh des choses plus
luxueuses. Voyez ce que se passe en
Chine par exemple. la Chine devient le
royaume de la consommation
et les gens achètent les grandes marques
surtout les marques qui sont très
médiatisé
et qui sont le symbole de luxe. Et donc
je pense que cette idéologie a eu du
succès. Elle a aussi contribué à créer
une classe moyenne assez importante en
Europe mais aussi dans les pays d'Asie,
les pays de l'Amérique latine. Mais il y
a un terme à tout. Et je pense que
aujourd'hui voilà le le modèle
néolibéral,
il ne fonctionne plus
comme on l'entendait qu'il qu'il pas
fonctionnait. Donc sans crise, c'est
quelque chose de de perpétuel. Et la
crise de 20082009, cette grande crise
financière a démontrait que on peut pas
faire toujours de l'argent sans être
puni pour ça. Et il y a toujours un
prix, un prix euh à n'importe quoi et il
y a un prix au fonctionnement de ce
modèle et ces crises vont se répéter. Il
y aura des victimes et une grande partie
de la population ne va pas faire partie
de ce ce royaume de consommation. Ils
vont être poussés à l'écart. Et voilà,
on voit déjà ça, c'est que ce ce modèle
ne fonctionne
pas d'une manière efficace. On voit ça
en Italie, on voit ça en France, on voit
ça en Allemagne même qui est un pays
assez aisé. On voit ça aux États-Unis
parce que monsieur Trump a été choisi
par ceux qui n'ont pas profité du modèle
modèle néolibéral. C'est ils sont les
perdants et donc ils ont voté un
outsider comme monsieur Trump qui
n'appartient pas à l'élite libérale
traditionnel américaine.
Euh ce qui rend assez difficile de
combattre ce modèle néolibéral, c'est
que justement c'est devenu une religion.
Ça a commencé comme une idéologie et
c'est devenu une religion. Ça s'est
marié au politiquement correct et on a
établi un certain nombre de maximes al
qu'on peut pas trc. Autrement, vous êtes
stigmatisé, vous êtes attaqué
immédiatement. Il y a des choses qu'on
peut pas dire.
Comme quoi ? comme par exemple euh
je peux vous donner une un exemple par
exemple, c'est euh l'Union européenne
critique euh la Hongrie
euh pour la raison que dans la
Constitution hongroise, il y a une
phrase qui dit que le mariage c'est une
union entre un homme et une femme. Et
donc
le l'idéologie et la religion
néolibérale
insiste que le mariage c'est une union
entre deux êtres humains. Il y a une
différence tout de même là. Et donc dans
je dirais que en Allemagne par exemple,
insister que le mariage c'est une union
entre un homme et une femme, c'est déjà
transgresser un peu les limites du
politiquement correct. On peut pas dire
par exemple que l'Europe ne peut pas
recevoir un nombre indéfini de
ressortissants de l'Afrique du Nord ou
du Moyen-Orient. Si vous le faites d'une
manière appuyée, vous vous allez être
critiqué. On va vous dire que vous êtes
raciste et ainsi de suite. Donc il y a
un nombre de choses qui sont qui sont
interdites à dire. Quand cette élite
libérale internationale définit son
attitude envers un certain phénomène,
tout le monde doit le suivre. Vous
voyez, Kaddafi, c'est un monstre. Euh,
Assad, c'est un tueur et ainsi de suite.
Ah, il doit y avoir une démocratie en
Syrie. Euh, pour une certaine raison, il
doit pas avoir de démocratie en Arabie
Saoudite. Donc, il y a beaucoup de
contradictions dans cette religion, mais
les gens ont cessé de réfléchir sur ça.
Il parce que une réfléch religion, c'est
une question de croyance. C'est pas une
question de d'intelligence. C'est les
gens les gens croient en quelque chose
et donc on le on leur suggère à quoi
croire ? [grognement] Euh ils
définissent et justement c'est euh on
revient à la question pourquoi la Russie
euh est tellement attaquée ? Pourquoi on
parle de la menace russe ? Mais c'est
parce que les journaux écrivent qu'il
faut avoir peur de la Russie. C'est
parce que les leaders politiques
européens américains disent qu'il faut
avoir peur de la Russie. Mais remarquez
que la Russie n'a attaqué aucun des pays
de l'Union européenne.
Alors, je vous coupe.
[raclement de gorge]
Premier cas de figure, la ferme de troll
russe de Saint-Pétersbourg.
Pour vous, c'est quoi ?
Pour moi, c'est une chose assez douteuse
parce que euh ça a été déclaré par la
commission de monsieur Müller. Je pense
qu'il y a 12 ou 15 noms qui ont été
énumérés. Mais écoutez, je ne peux pas
vous garantir qu'il y avait pas de 12 ou
15 personnes qui n'ont pas joué au jeux
dans les réseaux sociaux.
On parle de 4000 m carr qui viennent de
passer à 14000. Il y a un rapport de
l'armée française et du CAPS qui cite le
fait que cette usine à troll vient de
s'agrandir. Écoutez, je connais les
données de Facebook parce que elles ont
été fournies par monsieur
euh le
Oui. Fuckerberg à la commission euh de
renseignement au Sénat américain et il a
confirmé que le volume de cette incidie
de participation des des trolls russes
au trafic euh dans les réseaux sociaux
aux États-Unis était de 0,004
% du volume total de Facebook par jour.
Alors avec ça, vous voulez me dire que
avec ces 004
%, on peut influencer une élection
américaine ? Alors je trouve pas ça pas
ça pas ça sérieux. Le le la position du
gouvernement russe face à ce ce type, je
mets des guillemets, d'entreprise,
d'astroturfing, de modification de
perception de l'opinion publique, quelle
quelle quelle position a le gouvernement
russe quand il regarde cette entreprise
? Il laisse faire, il a un regardillant
? Est-ce que c'est connecté au
gouvernement russe ? Est-ce que vous
avez eu des échos ?
Je représente la branche législative,
donc je suis pas dans l'exécutif et je
ne peux pas vous donner la position du
gouvernement russe. Députés,
mais je le suis toujours. Je suis je
suis sénateur mais je ne fais pas partie
de l'exécutif. Donc le gouvernement,
c'est l'exécutif. Euh le gouvernement
euh a commenté brièvement toute cette
histoire et la logique des commentaires
de monsieur Poutine, c'était que on ne
peut pas répondre pour les activités
personnelles des gens qui veulent faire
partie aux réseaux sociaux à l'échelle
internationale.
Pas plus, pas moins. Euh
je pense que les réseaux sociaux
fournissent une plateforme idéale pour
essayer d'influencer les mentalité. Nous
savons que il y a des h des personnes
qui participent à au aux tentatives
d'influencer les mentalités en Russie,
en Chine et ainsi de suite. Je pense que
c'est un jeu international.
Euh je pense que c'est comme quand on
parle quand l'Amérique attaque l'Irak et
la Libye, elle parle d'agression russe.
Vous voyez ? Donc nous sommes accusés
des choses qui sont faites par les
autres, faites dans des volumes beaucoup
plus importants. Et donc je pense que
c'est un terrain où il faut peut-être
établir les règles les règles du jeu
comme dans le cyberfer, ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs Poutine a
proposé à Donald Trump d'établir un
groupe de travail sur le cyber warfare,
sur [grognement] la cyberguerre
pour établir des règles du jeu parce
qu'il y en a pas. Et c'est vrai que avec
des instruments de cyber cybergare, on
peut vraiment [grognement] provoquer des
crises d'électricité, débrancher des
centrales électriques, des en fait tout
le système d'infrastructure qui existe
dans les pays. Et donc il faut se mettre
autour d'une table et en parler. Et
Trump a dit d'accord, c'était à Hambourg
en 2018 pendant leur première rencontre.
Et puis il est venu aux États-Unis et il
a été attaqué par la presse américaine
et par les congressmannes et les
sénateurs américains qui lui disaient
"Mais écoutez, comment vous voulez faire
un groupe de travail avec l'ennemi et
les gens qui nous attaquent au niveau de
C'est bien." Et Trump a dit une phrase
tout à fait fantastique, une phrase
trempienne. Il a dit "Le fait que j'ai
donné mon accord pour la création de ce
groupe ne veut pas dire que ça va se
passer.
Donc voilà, c'est un peu on est là euh
quand on parle du dialogue avec
Américain sur cette question, mais à
vrai dire, c'est pas seulement les
Américains qui participent ou les
Britanniques. Voilà, maintenant ils ont
fait des déclarations qui euh qui ont
des capacités à produire des
catastrophes sur des
dans infrastructure russe parce qu'ils
ont des capacités de cybergerre eux
aussi, mais je pense que les Chinois ont
aussi des capacités. Et je pense que
même les Coréens du Nord ont des
capacités. Les Iraniens, je pense qu'ils
sont ils sont assez intelligents pour
avoir des capacités de faire ça. Et donc
c'est un domaine qui doit être réglé. On
a l'ONU qui règle les questions de
utilisation des forces militaires par
exemple ou les questions de
de de intégrité territoriale et ainsi de
suite. Mais ça ce sont les problèmes du
20e siècle. Il y a des problèmes du 21e
siècle qu'il faut régler. Donc le cyber
la cyber war, la cyberger guerre, c'est
un de ces problèmes. Et donc je pense
que à la fin des fin tout le monde on va
être obligé à établir des règles. Mais
ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que
quand on dit "Ah voilà, les Russes font
ça, les Russes font ça." Et qu'est-ce
que font les Américains ? Qu'est-ce que
font les Français ? Qu'est-ce que font
les Britanniques ? Qu'est-ce que font
les Iraniens ? Qu'est-ce que font les
Japonais ? Les les les Corroiens du
Nord, du Sud, qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Et
c'est justement ça. Est-ce que la Russie
doit euh s'abstenir de faire les choses
? qui sont faites par presque tous les
les grandes puissances ou les puissances
qui sont technologiquement avancées. Et
donc je je pense qu'il faut en discuter
pas seulement menacer la Russie, accuser
la Russie.
Vous connaissez la cathédrale de
Salzbury ?
Oui, j'en ai entendu parler récemment
beaucoup.
On creuse un peu.
Écoutez, je suis je suis pas des
services secrets, donc je peux pas dire
plus que ça.
Quelle était votre perception quand vous
avez vu nous, on leur a donné un surnom
ticket tac.
Ouais. faire une petit voyage
autour de l'affaire scripal.
Ça m'a paru assez étrange. Mais de
l'autre côté, encore une fois, il faut
voir les deux côtés de disons de de la
peinture. D'autre côté, ce qui me paraît
très étrange, c'est que depuis
une année presque, on voit pas ni
monsieur Scripal,
ni sa fille qui pourrait faire une
déclaration pas qui serait pas
transmise à travers le Scotland
euh ou les gens qui les entourent et qui
sont appartiennent évidemment au
services spéciaux britanniques.
On ne laisse pas la Scripal partir en
Russie bien qu'elle a dit pendant une
conversation téléphonique à sa sœur
qu'elle voudrait revenir. On n pas de
nouvelles de monsieur Scripal. Qu'est-ce
qui se passe avec monsieur Scripal ? On
sait pas. Ils disent pas qu'il est mort,
ils disent pas qu'il est vivant.
Pourquoi on le montre pas au monde ? Si
les britanniques étaient si sûr que
c'est une opération russe, je pense que
ça aurait été un coup assez fort de
montrer les deux victimes supposé qu'ils
disent des choses sur ça. Mais elles
sont silencieuses. Ce fameux Novitchok
qui peut envoyer en l'air toute une
ville, c'est utilisé
dans dans certaines quantités. il n'a il
n'a tué personne presque à part une une
dame qui paraît-il a trouvé un flacon de
euh un parfum de Ninarichi d'ailleurs
qui était euh enveloppé en plastique.
Donc il était ilfin d'une manière
professionnelle et son ami il a ouvert
ce plastique, il a pris ce flacon, il a
donné à madame madame c'est
c'est fait passer le parfume. Elle en
est morte 4 mois après cette histoire de
scripal. Et vous savez que le Novich
c'est une arme chimique binaire qu'il
faut mélanger dans des conditions de
laboratoire et qui ne tient pas
longtemps. Justement des armes binaires,
ils n'ont pas une longue période de
conservation. Alors après 4 mois, ce nov
serait décomposé même dans un flacon. Et
[grognement] donc ça ça me paraît
extrêmement étrange et mais on pose
beaucoup de questions à Russie mais
personne ne pose des questions au aux
anglais. Et quand [grognement] j'ai
parlé aux hommes politiques allemands,
français que les autres, ils disent
"Nous croyons, nous croyons madame
Thérèse May mais euh 2/3 de la nation
britannique ne croit pas ou plus madame
Theres May sur les autres questions.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a cette cette
profession de foi envers ce que dit
madame Théresa May ? Sans preuve, sans
rien du tout. Le président tchèque,
Miloch Zemman a dit "Mais écoutez leur
fait en Tchécoslovaquie une certaine
période". Oui, il a fait cette
déclaration. Puis il a dit "Mais je veux
des preuves, pas seulement des
déclarations, que ce sont les Russes qui
ont fait ça."
Donc c'est une histoire extrêmement à
mon avis extrêmement nébuleuse où les
britanniques ne disent rien, il
accusent, il ils vous fournissent des
euh des des pages dans le le les médias
britanniques, le Times, le S dans les
grands journaux britanniques que c'est
c'est un un attentat russe, que ce sont
des des Russes qui ont fait ça. Mais ce
qui se passe du côté britannique n'est
jamais expliqué et il y a un nombre de
questions à laquelle on n pas reçu de
réponse. Et donc je ne pense pas que je
dire plus.
Type question. Quel type de question ?
Mais comme j'ai dit, comment ce
Novitchok n'a pas réussi à tuer deux
personnes s'il a été appliqué contre ces
deux personnes ? Est-ce qu'on les a
trouvé sur sur une banquette quelque
part à Salzbury après qu'ils ont visiter
un restaurant sans conscience mais ils
étaient pas morts tandis que Novit c'est
très nocif c'est très nocif en tant que
arme chimique. C'est une arme militaire
et donc ils sont ils n'en sont pas
morts. Puis l'ami de la dame qui est
morte il il n'en est pas mort. Puis il y
a eu un policier qui était paraît-il
contaminé. À bout de 4 jours, il était
déjà guéri et sauf et il a dit que il
avait des sensations désagréable dans le
nez, dans les dans les yeux. Mais
écoutez, mais c'est pas sérieux parce
que une arme chimique binaire, ça vous
fait pas des sensations désagréables
dans le nez et dans les yeux. C'est une
arme neuroparalytique.
La personne, elle tombe, elle cesse de
fonctionner, c'est tout. C'est c'est
court. On peut pas sauver euh d'une
d'une application de Novoc une personne
si elle n'est elle euh si l'aide ne
vient pas dans les 10 minutes après
l'exposition. Et donc et voilà, c'est je
peux vous donner encore une dizaine de
questions sur ça. Et les britanniques,
ils n'offrent pas de questions, ils nous
posent des questions mais il n' pas de
questions. Et on dit d'accord écoutez
euh on voudrait tout de même avoir
accès. Ce sont les par exemple sa fille,
elle est citoyenne de la Russie, on
aurait droit à la voir au moins au
niveau consulaire. Elle est cachée
quelque part. Où est-elle ? Qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? [grognement] Donc c'est
une une histoire vraiment extrêmement
vague. Je pense qu'il y a très peu de
personnes qui connaissent la vérité et
moi j'appartiens pas à leur nombre.
L'Arabie Saoudite, est-ce que c'est un
partenaire fiable ? Est-ce qu'il faut le
considérer comme un partenaire ? Est-ce
qu'il faut le considérer comme un état
renégat ? Est-ce que cette théocratie
n'est pas contre-productive en tant que
partenaire ?
Mais c'est une question que je devrais
poser probablement à aux pays
occidentaux parce que c'est l'Arabie
Saoudite a été toujours le meilleur ami
des
pays euh démocratiques de l'Europe, de
l'Ouest et des États-Unis, de la plus
grande démocratie du monde. Comme vous
savez, les États-Unis, elle s'est fait
le plus grand ami de la plus grande
dictature du monde.
Et
je ne sais pas ce que je peux vous dire
parce que à vrai dire nos relations avec
l'Arabie Saoudite bien que nous avons
bien sûr des relations diplomatique mais
des relations plus approfondies ont
démarré il y a une année ou deux
seulement quand le roi de l'Arabie
Saoudite a visité Moscou à rencontré
monsieur Poutine je pense qu'il était
motivé par la la nouvelle faiblesse des
États-Unis au Moyen-Orient. Il a vu que
les États-Unis ne sont pas capables de
renverser le Corant des choses en Syrie.
Il a vu que les Américains sont en crise
permanente
dans leur politique dans cette région.
Je ne pense pas que les Saoudiens ont
beaucoup aimé la transfusion de
l'ambassade américaine à Jérusalem et la
reconnaissance de Jérusalem par les
États par les États-Unis en tant que
capital d'Israël parce que ça va à
l'encontre de tous les croyances et de
toutes les positions des pays musulmans.
Et donc ils ont décidé de ne plus mettre
tous les œuvres dans un panier, de venir
à Moscou et de voir ce qu'on peut faire
avec Moscou. Euh mon opinion
personnelle, c'est que dans le domaine
par exemple pétrolier, oui, je pense
qu'on peut se fier à l'Arabie Saoudite.
Ils ont une une grande tradition de
participer au marché international. Ils
sont membres de l'OPEC, cette
organisation Oui. de l'OPEP, cette
organisation de des pays pétroliers.
La Russie n'en fait pas partie. Non,
mais on a des pour parler avec les
l'Arabie Saoudite, on se met d'accord
sur les volumes de d'extraction du
pétrole, sur les questions de règlement
de prix pour que les prix ne s'envolent
pas très haut, ne pas ne tombent pas
trop bas. Et en tant que partenaire
commercial et dans le domaine pétrolier,
je pense que les Saoudiens sont tout à
fait fiables,
y compris sur leur déclaration de
réserve. Vous faites confiance dans les
Écoutez, je ne fais jamais confiance
mais je considère, j'analyse les
tendances et si je vois que pendant 30
40 50 années, l'Arabie Saoudite a rempli
ces obligations dans le domaine du
pétrole ou dans les sur les contrats
économiques, alors je dis que oui, c'est
un pays fiable. Mais quand je regarde la
politique de l'Arabie Saoudite par
exemple envers la Syrie, alors là, j'ai
beaucoup de questions parce que je suis
pas sûr que le meilleur moyen de
résoudre la question syrienne, c'est de
se tenir Japratan Nusra, les anciens
d'Al-Qaeda et toutes ces organisations
radicales islamistes qui fonctionnent en
Syrie et qui d'ailleurs
euh constitue un problème et lance un
défi à un régime laïque parce parce que
le régime de monsieur Hassad, c'est un
régime laïque et ils veulent faire
revenir la Syrie au Moyen-Âge. Ça c'est
absolument évident. Euh et donc là, je
suis absolument pas d'accord avec la
politique de l'Arabie Saoudite. Donc on
on est d'accord de gérer les questions
pétrolières avec elle, mais on est en
désaccord sur plusieurs éléments de la
crise syrienne, par exemple. Et aussi je
me pose la question quand on me dit que
les États-Unis par exemple ou bien
l'Allemagne ou bien la France voudrai
établir une démocratie en je dis ah oui
c'est très joli ça. Et puis j'entends
que ils vont le faire avec l'aide de
l'Arabie Saoudite et du Qatar. Et je me
demande et je me demande comment est-ce
qu'on peut établir une démocratie avec
l'aide des royaumes qui sont
autoritaires par définition. Et je pense
qu'on peut pas établir une démocratie.
Donc c'est faux. Le but c'est pas
d'établir une démocratie mais de
renverser monsieur Assad et de placer
quelqu'un qui serait probablement proche
de l'Arabie Saoudite et peut-être de ses
amis occidentaux. Mais ça c'est une
autre question hein. Euh vous voulez
changer un régime pour avoir votre type
à Damas, c'est une chose. Mais ne parlez
dans ce cas-là de démocratie.
C'est c'est le l'emballage le papier
cadeau qu'on vend aux populations
civiles.
C'est justement j'en ai parlé de
l'économie de consommation. Maintenant
il y a une politique de consommation
aussi. dans le domaine politique, on
vend des
concepts,
des concepts et des faux concepts aussi
et des fake news aussi. D'ailleurs,
c'est c'est pas nous qui avons inventé
la conception de fake news, c'est Donald
Trump. Ce qui est assez intéressant
parce que c'est lui qui a dit que les
grands médias américains sont en train
de produire des fake news. Et je suis
d'accord avec lui là, il a complètement
raison. Il y a eu énormément de fake
news sur lui-même par exemple. Euh il y
a énormément de fake news sur la Russie.
Quelqu comme fake news ? La golden
shower à Moscou des choses comme ça.
Et voilà voilà. Oui, à Moscou il a Ah
c'est quand même ce qu'il a écrit à la
base d'un rapport d'un ancien service
euh agent spéciaux des services
britanniques qui après a disparu pour 3
mois et puis il a dit que son rapport
n'était pas confirmé. C'est une
information qu'il peut pas confirmer
mais la New York Times l'a pris
immédiatement parce que euh aujourd'hui
la New York Times, elle n'écrit pas ce
qui se passe. Euh elle euh elle elle euh
publie des choses qui sont en train de
suivre une certaine une certaine ligne
politique. Euh c'est le le but c'est de
produire un résultat politique, c'est
pas d'informer les gens. Et donc le but
c'était de
stigmatiser monsieur Trump et de dire
que voilà, il est venu à Moscou, il a
pris des prostituées russe, il est allé
dans l'hôtel où euh monsieur Obama c'est
euh Oui. à séjourné pendant un certain
temps à Moscou, il a pris le même numéro
et il a désacralisé le lit où monsieur
Obama le le grand libéral
était avec les prostituées. Non mais
écoutez, mais c'est c'est quoi ça ? Et
c'est dans le New York Times et c'est la
presse jaune. Non, c'est c'est même
c'est c'est même pas la presse, c'est
quelque chose d'autre. C'est c'est la
poubelle. Mais c'est la poubelle parce
que il y a aucune preuve que ça a été
fait. Et d'ailleurs la New n'a plus
repris ce thème. Il y avait des trucs
pareils à la CNN. Et puis ils ont
démenti, ils ont dit "Oui, nous avons
fait une faute." Et donc tous les grands
médias américains euh ils ont tombé dans
ce piège de fake news à force d'être
partisan une presse partisane, une
presse qui préconise un but politique.
Elle n'informe pas, elle choisit
qu'est-ce qu'elle doit écrire pour
atteindre un but politique, renverser
monsieur Trump ou créer des conditions
pour son impeachment. Je suis pas un
très grand sympathisant de monsieur
Trump, mais je dois dire que oui, il y a
des fake news qui sont dirigés contre
lui. Il y a des fake news qui sont
dirigés contre la Russie. Euh et nous
vivons aujourd'hui dans le monde où
l'information est devenue euh à 50 % euh
une information fausse.
En France, on on a fait une loi pour les
fake news.
Ou
vous avez un avis dessus, vous voulez
commenter.
On
n pas de loi sur les fake news en
Russie. Mais
vous avez vous avez la liberté de la
presse en Russie ou pas ? Écoutez, la
liberté c'est une notion très relative,
je dirais. Euh mais on n' pas de loi sur
les fake news en Russie. Par contre, on
a des lois contre la calomnie. Pouvez
pas écrire des choses sur une personne
comme ça sans avoir rien derrière. Cette
personne peut aller à la cour et vous
demander une compensation ou enfin et
donc cette loi de calomnie, elle elle
limite un peu la presse bien sûr dans
les attaques personnelles, je dirais.
Mais on pas de on n' pas de loi contre
les fake news pour le moment. Moi je
pense que toutes les lois qui limitent
l'expression de la presse ont tendance à
devenir euh de la censure. C'est voilà,
je vais me limiter à ça. C'est c'est
pour les Français de décider s'ils ont
besoin de cette toi sur les fake news ou
non. Euh je suis pas spécialiste de de
l'information française. Je suis plutôt
spécialiste de des médias russes. Mais
si vous pensez que les fake news menace
constitue une menace informationnelle
pour la France, c'est à vous de décider
si vous en avez besoin. Mais je sais que
cette loi est beaucoup criti critiquée
en France même.
Il y a de la censure en Russie dans les
médias. Est-ce qu'il y a de la censure
et de l'autocensure ?
Euh il y a des traditions, je dirais.
Oui, il y a des traditions. Par exemple,
euh en Russie euh on euh on n pas même
on n' pas la même conception euh par
exemple que que la presse américaine euh
envers euh vous pouvez être en en en
désaccord avec le président
et il y a des radios, il y a des
stations de télévision, des exemples des
noms.
Oui. Et les échos de Moscou par exemple.
à la téléstation euh
d' en France et la pluie. La pluie euh
il y a des journaux comme la Gazette
indépendante Nisav Gazette, il y a Nv
Gazette, c'est la nouvelle la nouvelle
gazette. Bon et aussi des régionaux et
aussi dans les réseaux sociaux, il y a
énormément de sites qui attaquent
monsieur Poutine et ainsi de suite. Mais
euh on a une loi qui défend la
personnalité du président. Vous pouvez
l'attaquer pour sa politique, le
critiquer pour ça ou ça ou ça, mais vous
pouvez pas attaquer sa personnalité
d'une manière abjecte comme c'est fait
dans la presse britannique par exemple
ou dans la presse américaine. Donc il y
a certains éléments que la presse ne
peut pas se permettre mais il y a pas de
censure formelle. Il y a pas
d'institution
qui qui censure la presse. Il y a pas de
de de ministère de l'information. Voilà,
par exemple, voilà, il y a il y a le
ministère de la de des communications,
mais il y a pas de ministère de
l'information qui jouerait un rôle comme
dans le roman d'Orwell de 1984 qui dit
ce qu'il faut écrire, ce qu'il faut pas
écrire, ça n'existe pas.
[soupir]
Euh on on parle souvent de la Russie euh
en France et dans les pays occidentaux.
Comme quoi, c'est c'est un c'est un pays
qui est très compliqué pour les
journalistes, qu' y a des journalistes
qui sont assassinés, qui ont des
accidents, qui tombent de balcon, des
choses comme ça.
Ah oui, si
oui.
Je me rappelle pas que quelqu'un soit
tombé du balcon, c'était en Ukraine.
Ce qui est curieux, c'est que oui, ça
arrive. Et il y a eu il y a eu une
journaliste très connue qui a été tuée
il y a une une douzaine d'années, madame
Politkovsk.
Euh mais je dois vous dire que le pays
numéro 1 en Europe par le nombre de
journalistes qui ont souffert ou bien
péri à cause de leur activité
professionnelle, c'est l'Ukraine. Mais
ça vous vous le lirez jamais dans la
presse française ou dans la presse
occidentale parce que l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine
c'est l'enfant terrible aujourd'hui mais
l'enfant tout de même le régime
ukrainien c'est l'enfant terrible de
l'Union européenne et de des États-Unis.
C'est une question géopolitique. Ils ont
choisi l'Ukraine et ils ont décidé de se
de soutenir l'Ukraine contre la Russie
et donc tout ce qui se passait en
Ukraine, les mouvements nazi par exemple
et
euh la
euh la la
ce ce
cas très très connu. dans ce cas très
connu de quand une cinquantaine de
personnes ont été brûlées à vif à Odessa
le 2 mai et étranglé aussi et tué à
Odessa le 2 mai
on nous a dit enfin j'ai lu dans la
presse occidentale c'est accident
quelque chose non mais c'est brûlé
cétait prémédité c'était c'était préparé
ils ont été brûlés à vif et le conseil
de l'Europe s'est intéressé à cette
question mais le gouvernement ukrainien
n'a jamais donné de réponses et même le
conseil de l'Europe a dit que c'était
une enquête qui n'a pas été vraiment
conduite d'une manière professionnelle.
Et donc quand je vois que la Russie est
critiquée pour des choses Oui. qui sont
arrivées en Russie, c'est vrai,
certaines d'entre elles sont sont
réelles mais puis que l'Ukraine excède
ça par en il y a beaucoup plus de cas de
euh [grognement] de de journalistes tués
ou de de gens brûlés et là c'est la
presse passe à côté en disant "Mais non,
mais ça c'est c'est un petit excès de de
certains petits groupuscules de
radicaux. Mais c'est pas le cas, c'est
que en Ukraine, le président ukrainien
par exemple fait une photo avec les
militaires ukrainiens et un d'eux a une
insigne de SS sur sa forme militaire. Et
mais personne n'en parle, c'est normal.
Le président ukrainien peut être sur une
photo avec un type qui arbore uneesse.
C'est normal, c'est bon. Ça va, ça va.
Il y a il y a des organisations qui fait
le zrail qui chantent des chansons que
Hitler est notre père à tous. Bon, ça
passe, c'est normal quoi. C'est
l'Ukraine tout de même. C'est notre ami,
c'est c'est notre grand allié
géopolitique contre la Russie. En
Russie, vous n'avez jamais trouvé ça.
C'est cette démonstration de de nazisme
absolument ouverte que vous trouvez en
Ukraine. Et c'est seulement récemment,
il y a quelques journaux qui ont
commencé à dire que mais oui, tout de
même, il y a des organisations nazi en
Ukraine. Et donc, je pense que la raison
c'est c'est géopolitique. Comme dans le
cas de l'Arabie Saoudite, la Russie a
été sanctionnée pour être soupçonné
d'avoir utilisé une arme chimique contre
monsieur Scripal qui n'en est pas mort
et sa fille qui maintenant enfin ce que
je vois à la télévision quand il
apparaît du côté britannique, elle est
tout à fait saine. Il y a pas de
problème. Et monsieur Hashogi est tué
dans le consulat de l'Arabie Saoudite à
Istanbul mais il y a pas une seule
sanction appliquée par les pays
occidentaux parce que je ne parle pas
qui a donné l'ordre, je ne sais pas mais
le pays a reconnu que oui, c'est des
personnalités officielles qui sont
impliquées dans ce meurtre. Est-ce qu'il
y a une seule sanction par la France,
par la la Grande-Bretagne ? Il y a rien
du tout. Il y a il y a des déclarations
mais ça vaut pas grand-chose. Et donc
voilà, vous me demandez pourquoi est-ce
qu'on pas parle de l'Ukraine ? Pourquoi
est-ce qu'on applique pas des sanctions
contre l'Arabie Saoudite ? C'est la même
question que je peux vous poser.
Vous pensez que la la diplomatie
française c'est une diplomatie
d'opportuniste ? Écoutez, je suis pas
mal je suis je suis mal placé pour
donner des des euh des définitions de la
diplomatie française. Je pense que la
diplomatie française a de très bonnes
traditions euh en parce que la France
c'est un pays qui a déterminé la
politique en Europe pendant des
centaines d'années depuis je ne sais
plus depuis Saint-Louis je pense ou même
peut-être avant depuis les croisades.
Bon, c'est un grand pays, c'est un pays
important, c'est un pays qui joue un
très grôle dans un très grand rôle dans
l'Union européenne.
Puis vous avez eu de Gaulle, c'est un
pays qui a défendu sa souveraineté, qui
a été vainqueur dans la deuxème guerre
mondiale. Donc je pense que les
diplomates français sont très
professionnels. Moi, ceux que j'ai connu
et j'en ai connu
quelques-uns. Oui. Pierre Morel par
exemple, votre ambassadeur à Moscou,
Sylvie Berman qui est ambassadeur
aujourd'hui,
l'ancien ambassadeur qui a été été
maintenant envoyé à Pékin euh
le nom revient plus mais monsieur
Blanche Maison qui était ambassadeur que
que j'ai vu hier pendant ma présentation
au centre culturel russe. Enfin, tous
les ambassadeurs français que j'ai connu
sont des gens vraiment professionnels.
Vous avez connu Jacques Andréani ?
Non. Non, mais j'ai connu des diplomates
français comme je dis, j'en connais
aujourd'hui. Euh je pense que la France
joue d'après les règles qui ont été
choisies par ses dirigeants. Et les
règles, c'est que la France est membre
de l'OTAN,
la France est membre de l'Union
européenne, donc une certaine partie des
des fonctions nationales ont été
reléguées à Bruxelles. C'est Bruxelles
qui décide certaines questions. La
France doit être solidaire avec ses
alliés occidentaux. Par exemple, la
France n'a pas fait un grand cas de
l'affaire scripale, mais elle a soutenu
l'Angleterre et elle a je pense elle a
renvoyé deux ou quatre diplomates russes
en tant que mesure de répression. Donc
la France joue dans dans ce cadre qui a
été choisi par les présidents français.
Écoutez, Degul a renvoyé l'OTAN de de
Paris. C'est pour ça qu'il est à
Bruxelles. Il est sorti de de
l'administration de la l'organisation
militaire de l'OTAN en 1963 et 66.
Sarkozi nous l'a fait réintégrer.
Sarkozi a fait revenir la France. C'est
un choix français. C'est au français de
décider. Mais je pense que la diplomatie
française elle suit cette ligne qui est
définie par les les présidents qui sont
élus légalement par la population
française. Donc j'ai pas grand chose à
dire sur ça.
On a une question de notre équipe là.
Notre équipe a essayé plusieurs fois et
en vint d'inviter
le qu d'ors euh l'ambassade américaine,
l'ambassade de Suède et d'autres. Ils
ont tous décliné. Est-ce que pour vous
avez un début d'explication ? Est-ce
qu'ils ont peur de porter leur discours
en direct franc ?
Vous me demandez pourquoi il refusent
une invitation d'un d'un médiaire
français ?
Écoutez, c'est pas à moi de poser cette
question, c'est vous devez poser cette
question au quad c'est parce que que je
peux vous dire ? Je ne sais pas. Je ne
sais pas pourquoi elle décline. Je sais
que le ministère des affaires étrangères
russes est très très copain avec la
presse russe. Ça, je peux vous le dire
en coup sûr. Ils font énormément de de
briefing. Monsieur Lavrov est toujours à
la télévision, il est toujours dans les
journaux. Euh ils font ils font des des
conférences de presse régulièrement.
Donc on n pas ce problème là.
On les a contacté deux fois de suite et
leur temps de réponse est 18h et en
français.
18h et en français. Écoutez là, je peux
rien dire. Je travaille pas au cador non
mais là je parle de votre ministère des
affaires étrangères russes.
Vous a contacté en 18h il répondent et
il répond en français.
Ah écoutez alors là ça je peux pas vous
dire euh je je peux pas répondre de
toutes les réactions de du ministère des
affaires étrangères russes sur les
demandes de d'interview. Euh je pense
que probablement le ministre, il est un
peu submergé par ses par ses demandes.
Donc il il fait un nombre d'interviews à
l'interanger, mais je pense pas qu'il
peut répondre à toutes les demandes
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup.
Vous inquiétez pas, il répond très très
rapidement. Il y a pas de pas de
problème. On va revenir sur la Syrie et
sur la Libye. Est-ce que vous pensez que
la la Libye c'est la plus grosse erreur
française depuis les 10 dernières années
? Je pense que la Libye c'est une des
grandes erreurs de l'OTAN surtout parce
que c'était une décision collective.
C'est pas seulement la France mais
Grande-Bretagne qui a pris aussi cette
décision avec les États-Unis, avec
l'Italie. Donc c'est une opération
commune de l'OTAN. Je pense que ce qui
était absolument euh ignoré, c'est que
Kaddafi, quoi qu'on en dise, contrôlait
l'Afrique du Nord. Il contrôlait
l'immigration ou une grande partie de
l'immigration de l'Afrique du Nord. Il
s'est mis il s'est mis d'accord avec
monsieur Berlousconi d'établir un
système qui permettrait à à bloquer
voilà ces ces vagues incessantes qui
déferlent sur la côte sud de l'Europe en
Espagne ou en Italie. puis il ils
partent un peu partout dans l'Europe. Je
pense que Kaddafi euh était tout à fait
prêt à jouer ce jeu euh et à essayer de
de faire de la sorte que c'est en reste
en Afrique en Afrique du Nord. Et je
pense que de ce côté-là, il était un
personnage qui voulait donner une
garantie de sécurité dans la question
d'immigration à l'Europe. Après avoir
tué Kaddafi et réduit la Libye au chaos.
Comme on sait, il y a trois ou quatre
centres de décision aujourd'hui en Liby.
Personne ne contrôle plus cette
immigration.
Les gens se disputent qui va être le
leader suivant de la Libye. Donc c'est
un pays euh euh qui était organisé, qui
était contrôlé, qui était gouverné.
C'est un pays non gouverné, non
centralisé. Euh et donc voilà euh
monsieur Renziy, l'ancien premier
ministre de l'Italie euh a admis que
l'opération libenne c'était une
catastrophe. Et moi, je suis absolument
d'accord, c'était une catastrophe parce
qu'on nous a expliqué que euh il faut la
le but c'était d'établir une démocratie
en Libye. Alors voilà, maintenant on a
on a du chaos ça en Libye, mais pas une
démocratie.
La Syrie,
la Syrie, la Syrie, c'est compliqué. Je
peux vous dire une chose que
il y a eu le printemps arabe un peu
partout et un peu partout le printemps
arabe a créé beaucoup de rumeous comme
vous savez en Égypte, en Tunisie même
à
dans les pays du du Moyen-Orient. Mais
je pense que ce printemps arabe a été
utilisé par certains certains grandes
puissances occidentales,
stimulé,
stimulé, financé, organisé aussi euh
armé
ormé armé pour faire renverser un régime
qui ne corresponda correspondait pas aux
intérêts surtout des États-Unis parce
que comme j'ai déjà mentionné,
les autocraties du du golfe Persique,
bien qu'ils sont pas démocratiques,
bien qu'ils mettent en prison les hommes
sexuels et ainsi de suite, ils sont pas
considérés comme des
objectifs potentiel d'un régime change,
d'un changement de régime. Mais dans le
cas de monsieur Assad avec un régime qui
réussissait à marier plusieurs
religions, plusieurs groupes ethniques,
les drouses, les curdes, les sunnites,
les chiites, les chrétiens, ainsi de
suite. Pour une certaine raison, il a
été décidé que ce régime n'est pas
démocratique, il faut le renverser. Mais
pourquoi ne vous commencez pas par ses
voisins par exemple ? Donc la seule
raison c'est que monsieur Assassad à mon
avis avait des relation compliqué à
toujours avec Israël.
La raison c'est que il était considéré
pas comme un assez proche des
États-Unis, qu'il avait une politique à
lui-même, qu'il était historiquement
proche de Moscou. Son père était un
allié de Moscou. Et donc il a été décidé
de donner un coup de main, voilà, cette
résistance initiale et une résistance
qui était dans les rues. Il y avait des
manifestations, des némons sansion mais
tout de même c'est pas une guerre
civile. Tout de même, c'est pas une
guerre civile. Oui, même s'il y avait
quelques victimes. Et puis on a fait de
la sorte et avec la participation de
l'étranger surtout d'en faire une guerre
civile. Et c'est ça la Syrie. J'ai
visité la Syrie février 2012.
J'étais à Damas, les obus déjà tombaient
sur les alentours de Damas. On entendait
des explosions et tout ça, mais la ville
c'était une ville ouverte. Il y avait
pas de hijab, il y avait pas de
Bourkaille. J'ai pas vu une seule femme
qui qui était vêtu de cette manière.
C'était plutôt une ville du sud de
l'Europe, je dirais, avec des
restaurants, des terrasses ouvertes, des
cafés, euh beaucoup de trafic, enfin une
ville où les gens se sentaient à l'aise,
une ville européenne d'une certaine
manière, bien sûr, elle une ville arabe,
mais européenne a la manière de se
déplacer, de faire les choses, de de
s'habiller, de se conduire. Et donc,
j'ai pas ressenti une pression de
quelque sorte. Bon, c'est un régime
autoritaire, mais écoutez, à part la
Tunisie où est-ce qu'il y a des régimes
démocratiques au Moyen-Orient, il y en a
pas. Ils sont tous autoritaires d'une
manière ou d'une autre. Et je ne voyais
absolument pas de raison de renverser ce
régime pour des des raisons intérieures.
Par exemple, avec Kaddafi, on a dit que
nous sommes contre Kaddafi parce que il
menaçait la population civile de
Bengazier. Mais dans le cas d'Assad, il
menaçait personne. Il menaçait personne.
Mais quand l'insurrection a commencé,
quand ces gens ont été armés, poussé,
soutenu par les médias occidentaux,
financé par les États-Unis, par l'Arabie
Saoudite et les autres, et ben oui, il a
réposté. Qu'est-ce qu'il devait faire ?
Il devait faire quoi ? Dire "Ah, je je
fais mes valise, je m'en vais." Et donc
voilà, c'est ça la Syrie. La Syrie,
c'est une affaire de ingérence
internationale.
Il y a pas une histoire de de gazoduc.
Non. Non. Écoutez euh quand on explique
euh tout des euh des des grands procédés
processus politiques par des petit truc
économique et financier, un gaz Mais
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un gaz auuc qui
traverse la Syrie euh dans la
compétition moderne quand il y a le gaz
de schist américain, quand il y a les
grands gaz au qui viennent du
Turkménistan qui traversent la mer
caspienne et partent euh à travers la
Geéorgie et l'Azerbaïdjan vers la
Turquie et puis sur les marchés
mondiaux.
Quand il y a le gaz norvégien, il y a le
gaz des hollandais. Euh les anglais
aussi, ils produisent un certain nombre
de gaz. Vous avez du gaz liquifié en
Indonésie, au Qatar et ainsi de suite.
Et tout ça vient sur les marchés
mondieux. Un gaz de ça peut changer la
situation ? Non, absolument pas. Comme
vous avez remarqué, l'Iran est
sanctionné. Il ne peut plus vendre les
quantités de pétrole qu'il a vendu
jusqu'au 5 novembre. Les Américains ont
introduit les sanctions. Est-ce que ça a
influencé les prix du pétrole ? Non, les
prix du pétrole sont restés les mêmes.
Bien que euh un tiers du pétrolier
iranien ne euh n'est plus présent sur
les marchés mondaux. Donc un gaz auoduc,
c'est pas une raison de commencer une
grande guerre. Donc c'est pas le
gazoduc, c'est autre chose.
Quand on voit l'Allemagne dire que la
Russie est un partenaire quand même
important pour des questions
énergétiques.
Ouais. Parce que 35 % du gaz allemand,
c'est le gaz russe. 35 %, c'est
beaucoup. C'est beaucoup. Écoutez, je
comprends très bien les Allemands qu'ils
veulent construire ce courant Nostream
2, le courant du nord numéro 2 parce que
ça fera de l'Allemagne le centre le plus
important de répartition du gaz en
Europe du Nord. On a déjà effectué ce
projet avec les Turcs, le Southstream,
le Corant du Sud. Et la Turquie d'un
pays qui acheté du gaz maintenant va
devenir le hub principal dans la
Méditerranée de répartition du gaz. Mais
écoutez, chaque leader rationnel de son
pays serait intéressé par un projet
pareil. Surtout qu'il y a pas de
conditions politique. On demande rien à
la Turquie. On dit on le construit, on
vous fournit le gaz, vous nous payez,
vous le euh redistribuez, vous le vous
le vous le vendez sur les marchés
internationaux. Mais c'est bien pour
tout le monde. On ne demande pas à
monsieur Erdogan de changer sa politique
extérieure ou extérieure. C'est la même
chose avec l'Allemagne. On leur dit,
c'est un projet commercial. On vous vend
le gaz, vous avez autant de gaz que vous
voulez, vous le revendez aux hollandais,
aux Français, aux Autrichiens, je ne
sais plus à qui. Et bien sûr, les gens
rationnels en Allemagne disent "Mais
c'est un très grand projet."
Mais aussi il y a d'autres gens en
Allemagne qui disent "Mais les
Américains n'en veut pas. Les Américains
veulent nous vendre leur gaz de chiste
qui est 30 40 % plus cher. Il faut
l'acheter parce que ce sont nos alliés.
Et pour cette raison, il faut terminer
la construction du gaz de du russe.
Écoutez, alors vous choisissez hein,
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire ? Vous
voulez acheter le gaz de monsieur Trump
pour lui faire plaisir ou bien vous
voulez donner du gaz
stable ? C'est pas un gaz qui va arriver
par des navires et tout ça, c'est
compliqué. Du gaz stable qui va arriver
par un gaz auc depuis la Russie qui vous
fournit du gaz depuis les années 60 et
n'a jamais jamais détrompé personne sur
ce sur ces contrats. Donc c'est c'est
une question de choix pour les
Allemands. S'ils veulent avoir ce gaz,
je pense que ça est raisonnable d'avoir
ce projet. S'ils veulent acheter du gaz
beaucoup plus cher américain et de dire
et voilà, nous sommes vos disciples
qui vont vous suivre coûte que coûte.
C'est notre choix. C'est notre choix.
C'est à eux de décider.
Euh on on va sauter au-dessus de
l'Atlantique. Euh on a vu des beaux
avions russes arrivés au Venezuela.
Oui.
Des des bombardiers nucléaires tactiques
euh surnommé
stratégique, merci. Euh surnommé par
l'Occident les Black Jack.
On les appelle les T 160.
Ouais, les T 160. Euh Tupolèv 160.
Voilà. Euh c'est euh un remake de Cuba,
c'est montrer que la Russie amène des
avions à frappe nucléaire à côté des
États-Unis. C'est quoi ?
Ah, c'est un signal euh
qui est conditionné par le fait que
le temps est venu militairement aux
frontières.
de la Russie. Il y a 4000 Estoniens.
Non,
pardon.
En Estonie, vous parlez de l'Estonie là
?
Estonie, Lituanie et Lonie, les trois,
les Républiques baltes qui qui ont une
longue frontière commune avec la Russie
et donc il y a 4000 soldats de l'OTAN
qui sont stationnés là-bas. D'ailleurs,
je pense qu'il y a 900 euh militaires
allemands qui sont placés en Lituanie.
C'est la première fois que l'Allemagne
envoie ses troupes après 1941
sur le territoire de l'incienne Union
soviétique, ce qui est un assez
controversé à mon avis. Ah bien que
c'est sous les guides de l'OTAN, mais
tout de même c'est c'est un retour euh
qui pose des questions. Euh il y a euh
les navires américains qui pénètrent de
temps en temps la mer noire. En
[grognement] Polne, ils sont en train de
créer un nouveau étatmajeur de l'OTAN et
les Polonais veulent construire une
nouvelle base militaire qu'ils veulent
nommer la base de Donald Trump. Donc
vous voilà
euh donc l'OTAN est là, il est près de
nos frontières. Euh on le voit très
bien, on le comprend très bien. L'OTAN
promet à la Géorgie et à l'Ukraine dans
un certain temps de les emmettre
admettre à l'intérieur de l'alliance. Je
veux souligner que tous ces comptes de
fait qu'on nous racontait dans les
années 90 et j'ai connu tous les
secrétaires générals de l'OTAN depuis
Manfred Verner jusqu'à Vill Class et euh
Xavier Solana puis j'étais plus
intéressé parce que cit toujours la même
chose, on a raconté que le temps c'est
une organisation extrêmement pacifique.
C'est presque un jardin d'enfants où on
instruit les nouveaux pays à la
démocratie que oui, ils ont un ancien
fusil mais il est caché derrière la
porte. On sait même plus tirer. Et puis
en 1999, ils ont bombardé la
Yougoslavie. En 2011, ils ont bombardé
la Libye et puis ils font déjà une
vingtaine d'années la guerre en
Afghanistan. Donc on en a déduit que le
temps, c'est tout de même une
organisation militaire. Et c'est pour ça
qu'on a des soupçons. Quand le temps
fait des manœuvres à 100 km de Calingrad
dans l'est de la mer Baltique avec la
participation des Finlandais et des
Suédois, on se dit "Mais pourquoi ils
font ça ?" Hein ? Et dans ce grand jeu
international sur les chiqu
international, [grognement]
on doit faire quelque chose parce que si
les figures de votre adversaire vous
attaquent sur les chiquier, il faut il
faut réposter hein. Et alors voilà, il y
a deux bombardiers qui se sont envolés
mais remarquez pas à Cuba pour le
moment. Euh oui, ils sont allés à
Venezuela. Et ça démontre les capacités
militaires russes et ça c'est évident.
Euh
euh les Américains ont réagi assez
nerveusement. Ils ont dit que euh il ne
voit pas de but à ce vol et ainsi de
suite. Mais c'est à nous de définir si
et au Venezuela qui les a reçu. Euh si
il y a un but. Euh je pense que il y a
aussi c'est aussi un signal pour les
Américains que le scénario militaire de
la solution de la crise vénézuélienne
dont monsieur Trump a parlé n'est pas
évident.
Il n'est pas évident, on n'est pas
neutre sur cette question. C'est aussi
un petit signal pour eux. Et puis aussi,
c'est oui, c'est un certain retour de la
Russie en Amérique Amérique latine, mais
c'est pas Cuba tout de même. On veut pas
provoquer une nouvelle crise de Caribe.
Ça c'est aussi vrai. On on a des copains
qui se baladent en Afrique en ce moment.
On a déployé un réseau pour s'informer
de ce qui se passe en Afrique. Bad en
Afrique.
Ouais. Oh bon, les Américains se
baladent là-bas depuis souvent, depuis
longtemps. Là, on voit beaucoup de
Russes se balader en Afrique,
des militaires, des instructeurs, des
choses comme ça. Est-ce que vous avez
des choses pour nous éclairer ?
Qu'est-ce que la Russie fait en Afrique
?
Écoutez, la Russie a des activités
diplomatiques en Afrique officielle.
Elle a des activités économiques et
commerciales officielles et puis un
certain il y a un certain nombre de gens
qui sont intéressés dans l'Afrique comme
il y a des gens qui sont intéressés à
l'Afrique. Oui. Euh en Angleterre, en
France, aux États-Unis comme vous l'avez
dit. Bon, écoutez, on
on n'est plus l'Union soviétique. Donc
nous avons des
des euh des compagnies qui font le
commerce avec
qui ils veulent, on va dire. Euh on a
des groupes
comme on dit, paramilitaire par exemple.
Si un gouvernement africain veut que ces
groupes par militaires fournissent la
sécurité à ce gouvernement ou à une
partie de ce gouvernement, c'est c'est
assez gens de décider. C'est par la
Russie qui est responsable pour les
citoyens qui ont des contrats personnels
avec un tel ou tel gouvernement
africain. Et donc c'est c'est ce que je
peux vous dire, c'est que en Afrique ça
se passait toujours. Le écoutez un peu
nouveau, c'est que la Russie est de
retour et ça peut agacer les gens. Mais
écoutez, on est tout de même une grande
puissance. Il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont intéressés par l'Afrique, par
l'Asie, partout.
Donc il y a beaucoup de touristes dans
le monde aussi. Il y a pas seulement des
militaires, des
des
nouveaux touristes, c'est ça ? Bien bien
non, j'ai dit qu'il y a beaucoup de
touristes, il y a pas seulement des
militaires. Si si vous n'auriez jamais
vu des Russes à la Côte d'Azur par
exemple ou à la rivière italienne et des
militaires quelque part où dit "Mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? les gens ne
viennent pas et il y a des militaires
mais comme tout le monde voyage
aujourd'hui avec des buts différents.
Donc [rires]
euh on va on va repartir sur la Russie.
Ça, on est où ? La corruption en Russie.
La corruption en Russie.
et tout ce qui va bien.
Euh la mafia
dans la forme italienne en tant que clan
stable avec des réseaux international
des gens tués avec
une une
un truc enfoncé dans la bouche ou
quelque chose. Non, ça on l'a pas. Ça on
l'a pas. Le crime organisé, je pense que
oui. Euh dans les années 90, début 2000,
il y avait beaucoup d'extorion.
Maintenant, il y a il y a beaucoup
moins. Il a presque pas. Les grands
criminels, les groupes criminels qu'on
avait au sud de la Russie surtout, ces
gens-là sont en prison. Donc c'est
plutôt la corruption, c'est plutôt la
corruption euh des des hauts
fonctionnaires, des
sénateurs.
Il y a eu quelques sénateurs qui ont été
arrêtés.
Maintenant, depuis que je suis au Sénat
euh et même depuis que je suis à
l'Assemblée euh fédérale en Russie, donc
ça fait 7 ans, j'ai pas entendu un seul
cas d'un sénateur arrêté. Par contre,
six gouverneurs sont en prison. Voilà
parce que les sénateurs n'ont pas accès
au moyen financier. Les sénateurs sont
les représentants des régions dans le
parlement russe. Et donc ils ne pas
n'ont pas un moyen direct de contrôler
les finances tandis que les gouverneurs,
c'est les gens qui sont financièrement
responsables. Et dans les trois
dernières années, six gouverneurs, le
gouverneur de Sahalin et de plusieurs
grandes régions de la Russie ont été
arrêtés pour corruption. Certains de
attendent
voilà la le cours de justice. Il y a des
enquêtes. Un de ces gouverneurs a été
arrêté quand il était en train de
toucher un pot de vin de 400000 dollars.
Donc il était pris avec l'argent. Donc
il y a aussi une lutte contre la
corruption.
Euh nous avons une institution qui
s'appelle le comité d'investigation SL
Commissed. Ça a été créé spécialement
pour traiter les cas de corruption aux
échelles supérieures du pouvoir.
C'est financé comment ? Par qui ?
C'est financé par l'État. C'est uneation
budgétaire. C'est des c'est des
policiers quoi qui mais qui se
spécialisent en des cas de corruption
justement. C'est pas des crimes pardon.
Combien de fonctionnaires ? Ah, je me
demande [soupir] mais je peux vous dire
que euh l'année dernière, ils ont
traduit 78000
cas criminels de corruption dans les
cours. 78000 ?
Oui, c'est c'est beaucoup hein. Donc il
fonctionne.
Euh, parlons un petit peu euh des
prisons. Je sais que nos prisons n'ont
pas grand-chose à vous enver à du moins
envie à vos prisons. Comment ça se passe
les prisons en Russie ? toujours un
petit peu le le goulag avec des
extorsions, des gens qui se font
tabassés, des choses comme ça.
Écoutez, à vrai dire, c'est c'est un des
éléments de notre de notre vie que je ne
j'ai pas vraiment étudié parce que je
m'occupe un peu d'autres choses. Euh
donc, je me je m'occupe des de
l'information. Je m'occupe aussi
des affaires des gens euh qui viennent
vers moi comme sénateur avec des
problèmes qu'ils ont eu dans des cours
de justice avec la police qu'ils jugent
qu'ils ont été traités d'une manière non
convenable ou que il y avait des
accusations qui n'avaient pas pas été
bien fondées pour les traduire en
justice et ainsi de suite. J'ai réussi à
renverser renverser déjà quelques cas et
on en parle dans les médias russes. Mais
les prisons, c'est pas vraiment mon
domaine. Enfin, je pense que dans les
prisons, dans le monde entier, il se
passe des choses qui se passent dans les
prisons. Alors, écoutez, quand je j'ai
pris l'avion pour visiter la France
aujourd'hui, j'ai vu ce film fameux,
bien que c'est la France d'entente bien
sûr, mais c'est le papillon. Vous avez
entendu parler du papillon ? Non, c'est
un bagnard français qui a été accusé
pour meurtre qu'il n'a pas commis. et
qui a été envoyé en en Guyane française
en Amérique latine et qui a fait quatre
ou cinq tentatives d'évasion et puis
s'est échappé à la fin. Son nom est
Henry Charière, c'est un personnage
réel. Et voilà, on on montre la bagne
française ou le bagne français euh et
bon, il y a des choses qui s'y passent
paraît-il d'après le film. Donc je pense
que les prisons c'est un monde à part.
Ça existe plus le bail en France hein.
D'accord. Mais il y a des présidents
tout de même. Donc c'est un monde à
part. C'est un monde qu'il faut
connaître bien pour en juger. Moi je
suis pas vraiment dans cette position.
Eh
on va parler des LGBT, des gay et de
tout ce mouvement. Comment ça se passe
en Russie ? En Russie euh
les relations homosexuelles ne sont pas
interdites. Euh euh la loi de l'Union
soviétique qui interdisait ces relations
a été révoquée.
Il y a une un choix personnel libre de
la euh de du partenaire.
Euh par contre, on n'admet pas les
mariages homosexuels, ça non.
Euh il y a deux raisons pour ça. La
première c'est la réaction de la société
qui n'accepte pas ses mariages. Elle
accepte des unions civiles. Si les gens
vivent ensemble, ils ont des biens
communs, c'est à eux de décider.
Pas de problème d'héritage ou de choses
comme ça.
Voilà, justement qu'on a des des lois
que par exemple si vous avez vécu un
partenaire pendant un certain bout de
temps, vous pouvez hériter de de ses
biens. Voilà, qu'il soit homme ou femme,
femme ou homme mais pas de mariage
aussi. La Russie est un pays de où la
religion joue un grand rôle. Euh, on a
la l'église orthodoxe qui est assez
assez puissante. Elle a beaucoup
d'influence. Deux tiers des Russes se
considèrent comme des chrétiens
pratiquants,
même s'il vient dans l'église deux fois
par année, mais déjà ça leur permet de
dire que ils sont des chrétiens
orthodoxes pratiquants. Et bien sûr
l'église enfin l'église russe est
contre. Et donc c'est comme comme en
Chypre, comme en Grèce, c'est un peu
voilà le côté oui de l'Église orthodoxe
qui euh qui est beaucoup plus rigoureuse
sur cette question que l'Église
catholique par exemple. Puis on a des
démonstrations d'homosexuelles aussi.
Euh
c'est autorisé ?
Oui, c'est autorisé. Par contre, quand
il veut faire une démonstration dans la
sur la ha centrale de Moscou, parfois
c'est interdit. On leur dit "Non, mais
pas ici mais autre part." Mais ils
disent "Non, mais on veut le faire ici."
C'est plus plus visible. C'est plus
visible mais c'est aussi c'est plus
dangereux parce que la direction des
gens peuvent être parfois brutales. Je
peux vous rencontrer une histoire. Les
autorités de Geéorgie à Biliss ont donné
une autorisation d'une démonstration
homosexuelle au centre de Bicis, c'est
la capitale de la geéorgie pour
démontrer à l'Europe qu'ils sont
européens, ils sont démocratiques,
qu'ils sont tolérants et ainsi alors les
les homosexuels qui ont pris part à la
démonstration ont été battus
physiquement par les gens, les
geéorgiens, par les agents de police. La
police les protégeait mais il y a eu une
très grande bagarre. Beaucoup de
personnes ont été cognées par les gens
[grognement] qui considéraient que ils
ne veulent pas voir une démonstration
d'homosexuelle au centre de la ville. Ça
s'est passé aussi à Montenegro euh qui
euh est un membre appliquant de l'Union
européenne. Donc euh voilà, pour des
raisons de sécurité, pour des raisons de
réaction publique euh les homosexuels
ont le droit de manifester en Russie
mais pas évidemment sur la place rouge.
Oh, c'est dommage. C'est beau la place
rouge.
Oui, c'est beau la place rouge, mais ils
peuvent la visiter à titre personnel, il
y a pas de problème. Bon euh
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui disent
que le mouvement des gilets jaunes
n'aurait jamais pu euh s'opérer en
Russie parce que Vladimir Poutine
n'aurait jamais laissé faire ça.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Je pense que les gilets jaunes
deviennent une culture internationale
parce que j'ai entendu parler qu'en
Israël c'est les casques jaunes déjà.
Ouais. Dans plusieurs pays, en Belgique
quelque part, c'est les gilets jaunes.
Donc si ça devient une culture de
protestation
comme le mitou,
le les femmes agressées ou dites
agressées par des hommes, c'est devenu
international un peu dans le monde
entier. On en parle aussi en Russie.
Donc si ça devient une culture de
protestation, ça peut venir en Russie
que les gens qui protestent aujourd'hui
sans gilets jaunes vont protester avec
des gilets jaunes. Je ne vois pas en
quoi ça va vraiment changer la donne. Ça
c'est c'est la forme, c'est pas la
substance. Mais je ne pense pas qu'il y
aura des gilets jaunes enfin copiés sur
les gilets jaunes français en Russie. Je
ne pense pas.
Est-ce que vous trouvez que la France
l'usé d'une répression
disproportionnée par rapport au
mouvement des gilets jaunes ?
J'ai vu à la télévision beaucoup de
cadres de voitures enversé brûlé de
vitrines
brisées. On dit que c'est les casseurs
et que la police a le droit de réposter.
Donc
j'étais pas à Paris pendant pendant ces
ces moments de protestation.
J'ai vu que il y a des casseurs, il y a
des gens qui euh
évidemment ont violer la loi. C'est
c'est évident. Euh dans quelle partie
c'est c'est ils font ils font partie du
mouvement des gil jaunes où ils sont à
l'extérieur ce moment. Je peux pas en
juger
mais je sais que quand les
démonstrations
atteignent un certain niveau de violence
la police police commence à roster.
Alors ça c'est pour la France. En ce qui
concerne la Russie, je peux vous dire
que il y a eu jamais de démonstration
pareille de force
en Russie pendant les démonstrations de
protestation qu'on a vu en France
pendant les démonstrations des g ja
jaunes. Alors là jamais. Ce qu'on peut
faire vraiment, c'est de Il y a des
policiers qui euh qui arrêtent un
manifestant, il le faut entrer d'une
manière un peu brutale dans un bus et
puis il est emmené dans une station de
police.
Mais
on sait plus ce qui se passe.
Euh non non, ils ils sont relâchés. Euh
ça dépend de du délit qu'ils ont commis.
Si c'est seulement ils ont pris part à
la manifestation, ils sont relâchés vers
le soir même. S'ils ont brisé, cassé
quelque chose, attaquer quelqu'un, ça
peut durer jusqu'à 15 jours. C'est c'est
le maximum.
Euh donc mais j'ai j'ai pas vu vraiment
de de de bataille entre la pub avec du
sang versé et ainsi de suite. Donc
euh écoutez
mais c'est une en Allemagne aussi quand
il y a des protestations, il y a il y a
des cas où les gens sont blessés. Ah
c'est excessif ou c'est pas excessif ?
C'est très relatif. Ça dépend de
l'ampleur des protestations. Ça dépend
s'ils sont des protestations violentes
ou non. Donc chaque cas, je je pense
doit être étudié et a une organisation
pour ça, c'est le Conseil de l'Europe.
La France est partie du Conseil de
l'Europe. Voilà. Est-ce que vous avez un
conseil à donner pour renverser un
gouvernement en étant civil, euh sans
violence, sans rien si on veut destituer
son gouvernement ?
Un conseil. Ouais,
mais je suis pas un conseiller pour un
changement de régime. Je pense que tout
doit passer par euh par les procédure
légales, les élections
et c'est le moyen de renverser un
gouvernement si vous voulez faire
changer participer aux élections. Mais
écoutez, mais voilà, par exemple, on
nous a expliqué qu'en Ukraine, c'était
la révolution et c'est pour ça
l'occident l'a soutenu.
Alors bon, c'est un peu de démagogie à
mon avis.
Mais il paraît que la révolution est
aussi admise par la mentalité politique
occidentale en tant qu'instrument de
renversement de gouvernement pourvu que
c'est pas un gouvernement d'un pays
occidental.
Révolution de couleur.
Euh oui, révolution orange comme on les
Ouais. Euh ce qui m'a frappé par contre,
c'est que
h
la France a protesté quand monsieur
Trump a fait un tweet en disant que il y
avait des des manifestants qui créaient
son nom pendant Ouais, c'est ce que j'ai
entendu dire. qui créait son nom pendant
les manifestations, qu'il voudrait un
trempe en tête de la France. Et euh
le Kedor a placé une protestation contre
ça. Il a dit aux américains qu'ils
doivent pas
inérance dans la politique intérieure,
c'est ingéré dans les affaires
domestiques. Oui. politique intérieure
de la France.
Et je suis absolument d'accord avec le
cas d'Orsac. Mais ma question, pourquoi
est-ce que nous avions vu tellement
d'Européens sur le maïane ukrainien
quand ces manifestants voulaient
renverser le gouvernement légal en
Ukraine ? Il paraît que en Ukraine, on
peut s'ingérer dans les affaires
intérieures du pays. C'est même c'était
même recommandé. Il y avait un grand
nombre de députés allemands européens du
Parlement européen, John Mcin des
États-Unis, le ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'Allemagne, monsieur
Wester Bellet qui sont venus en disant
que oui, le MAN a raison, nous vous
soutenons, nous sommes derrière vous,
vous deviendez une démocratie. Alors,
c'est interdit quelque part mais c'est
admis autre part. Alors là, j'ai une
grande question. C'est quoi ça ?
les élections européennes, on accuse la
Russie de vouloir faire basculer.
On accuse la Russie de tout.
Écoutez,
tout pas tout.
On a commencé on de presque on a
commencé par ça. Les journaux
britanniques ont accusé la Russie d'être
derrière les gilets jaunes. J'ai vu un
article dans le Times qui a dit que mais
c'est les Russ c'est Rus. J'ai
le Drian Ludrian va faire une enquête.
Non.
Ah je Oui, j'ai entendu parler. et aussi
les services spéciaux ukrainiens ont dit
que oui, c'est les services secrets
russes qui sont derrière les gilets
jaunes. Et ce que je veux proposer,
c'est que il y a des Ukrainiens qui
viennent expliquer aux gilets jaunes qui
que ce sont les Russes qui sont
derrière. Je veux voir la réaction des
gilets jaunes parce que je ne pense pas
qu'ils ont vu un seul russe pendant
toutes ces manifestations et même avant.
Donc euh la Russie est accusée
d'ingérence
à mon avis aussi, elle était accusée par
exemple par la presse italienne de
soutenir la ligue de euh de monsieur
Salvini. Oui, c'est dans tous les pays
où il y a un développement qui ne
convient pas aux élites traditionnelles
libérales, la Russie est accusée dans de
faire partie de ce changement. Mais à
vrai dire, c'est la Russie n'a rien à
voir avec ça. C'est que je pense que les
élites traditionnelles européennes n'ont
pas de réponse aux question qui sont
posés par les sociétés européennes. Et
c'est ça la c'est ça la raison. Il
il faut un épouvantail.
Oui, justement un skapegat, comment ça
s'appelle ? Un bouqu émissaire. un bouc
émissaire parce que mais euh quand quand
il y avait eu cette élection, la
dernière élection parlementaire en
Allemagne, il y avait beaucoup de rumeur
que les Russes vont essayer d'influencer
[grognement] euh l'élection et puis il y
a eu une déclaration des services
spéciaux allemands qui ont dit que il y
a pas d'ingérence et le The Built, le
grand journal allemand, il a titré en
première page mais où sont les Russes ?
parce que on a pas trouvé pendant les
élections allemandes. Donc on indique
que la Russie participait au Brexit mais
c'est pas nous, c'est Nigel Farage,
c'est les Britanniques qui ont fait le
Brésil. C'est c'est monsieur Johnson,
l'ancien ministre d'affaires étrangères,
monsieur Farage, le leader du parti de
l'indépendance de la Grande-Bretagne.
C'est une tradition antie-européenne
dans le pentier parti conservateur
depuis Maic. Depuis strict, c'est pas
les Russes, c'est les Britanniques. Mais
comme cette élite libérale
internationale qui gouverne l'Europe,
elle doit expliquer aux populations
pourquoi ça marche mal. Et donc ils ont
trouvé c'est les Russes. Les Américains
perdent la compétition internationale,
c'est les Chinois.
Quelque chose va mal en politique en
Russie euh pardon en Europe, c'est les
Russes. Ça n'a rien à voir. Il y a
aucune preuve. Il y a rien du tout.
C'est
Qu'est-ce qui va mal en Russie en ce
moment ? Qu'est-ce qui va mal en Russie
?
Écoutez euh [soupir]
je pense que on voudrait
une croissance économique beaucoup plus
importante. Je pense que enfin on est
mieux aujourd'hui que il y a 3 4 années
quand c'était une croissance zéro ou
même négative en dans les années de la
crise financière. Aujourd'hui, c'est
1 % de 1 %
euh 1,7 %. C'est passé. C'est Je ne
pense pas que l'économie démontre une
croissance acceptable. Je voilà. et
aussi cette croissance est deux fois
inférieure à la croissance mondiale.
Donc je pense que là c'est ça va pas
très bien. Aussi une des raisons c'est
les sanctions internationales bien sûr
les sanctions américaines, les sanctions
de l'Union européenne il jouent un
certain rôle.
Euh je pense que
[soupir]
il y a eu un problème de crédibilité du
pouvoir à cause de la réforme
pensionnaire. Ouais. La retraite,
on a fait bouger la retraite de 5 ans
pour les femmes et de de 5 ans pour les
hommes. Donc de 55 à 60 et de
Espérance de vie en Russie, c'est
combien ?
Espérance de vie, c'est 60
71 72. Voilà. Dernière bougé la retraite
à quel âge et quel âge ?
Pardon,
vous avez fait échanger l'âge de la
retraite du départ ?
C'était 60 ans pour les hommes,
maintenant c'est 65
mais ça va ça va venir, c'est un système
progressif, je veux dire. Donc ça va
être le processus va être terminé en
seulement. Donc vous comprenez, c'est
c'est c'est fait par étape. Et pour les
femmes c'était 55, ça va être 60.
Mais comme partout dans le monde, ça a
généré beaucoup de protestations
et les gens les gens sont pas contents.
C'est vrai. Mais aussi vous avez vous
savez, j'ai j'ai lu il y a une dizaine
d'années un livre d'un sociologue
américain qui s'appelait The Grey Done,
l'aube grise.
Elle parle ce bouquin enf cette étude
plutôt, elle parle de cette
de ce destin des pays avancé que d'avoir
de plus en plus de pensionnaires, de
retraités et de moins en moins de
travailleurs, de gens qui vont
travailler et alimenter ces ces
retraites et donner leur la possibilité
d'avoir une vie décente. Et donc c'est
voilà, on est venu aujourd'hui en Russie
aussi voilà à cette limite quand on peut
faire face à cette grise, ce qui veut
dire des gens âgés qui vont devenir la
majorité de la population. Donc euh
c'est une réponse à ce défi
international. Et donc je savais que il
y aurait des gens malheureux à cause de
ça. Je savais que le gouvernement va va
perdre de sa popularité. C'était
absolument évident. Mais c'est une
réforme qui est faite un peu partout,
différemment mais partout parce que il y
a pas moyen de soutenir une population
énorme de retraités par une population
réduite de gens qui qui vont chaque jour
au travail. Donc je pense que c'était
inélectable d'une certaine manière.
Quoi d'autre ? Qu'est-ce qui va mal ?
Hm.
La qualité des
des routes russes est toujours
inférieur,
mais aussi il faut prendre le climat en
compte parce que quand vous avez par
exemple - 25 l'hiver et + 30 l'été,
c'est pas comme en Égypte où vous avez
fait une route, elle fonctionne pour 50
années, elle est plus ou moins
intacte et ainsi de suite parce que
chaque fissure, il y a de l'eau avec du
qui entre mais il y a aussi beaucoup de
d' inefficacité
voilà dans ce domaine. Voilà ça c'est un
problème national parce queon a un pays
énorme.
L'espérance de vie tout va bien.
L'espérance de vie ça monte oui enfin
le degré de sid le degré de sida oui
c'est un grand problème aussi. La drogue
de synthèse,
pas tellement. Le sida plutôt. Ouais, le
[grognement] sida plutôt la on a on a
des fondations qui qui s'en occupe mais
je pense que il faut faire plus.
Il y a de la enfin de de la propagande
de des mesures qu'il faut prendre, ces
trucs tout ça. Puis aussi on a on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui de la nécessité de
ne pas faire des des gens qui sont
touchés par la sida des des marginaux
dans la société. Il y a des programmes à
la télévision, on en parle que le sida,
on meurt pas de la sida elle-même, on
meurt des conséquences. Donc personne
peut être bon saine,
être porteur de la sida mais mourir à 90
ans une autre maladie. Bon euh donc
parce que bien sûr il y a une certaine
réticence dans la population surtout la
population des petites villes dans rural
[grognement]
le sida.
Ah mais c'est un problème là, je je peux
pas le nier mais enfin on essayer de
s'en occuper.
La Chine, est-ce que c'est pas un
partenaire qui est
dangereux pour la Russie ?
La Chine est grande. Ouais, c'est
1300500
milliard. Ouais 1ARD 3 50000 habitants
et ça crée bien sûr une certaine
pression psychologique.
Mais la Chine c'est aussi un pays qui
ayant été un empire pendant longtemps
la Chine a une notion très claire des
rapports de force.
Donc si la Russie reste la première
puissance nucléaire comme elle est
maintenant avec les États-Unis,
avec une armée forte
et un gouvernement central considéré
efficace et capable de défendre son
territoire, je ne vois aucunement de
de menace chinoises qui [grognement] qui
pourrait entre la Russie et la Chine
bien que nous avons 4000 et demi de
kilomètres de frontière. Donc le
autrement autrement, écoutez, mais tout
le monde doit compter avec la Chine,
tout le monde. Euh nous sommes
partenaires privilégier avec la Chine.
Je dirais des
partenaires ou amis.
Euh partenaire et amis en même temps, ça
progresse.
Avec la France, vous êtes partenaire ou
ami ?
Avec la France, je pense qu'on est ami
historique,
partenaire partiel, sympathisant.
[rires]
Bel effet de manche. Euh, on pourrait
vous garder pendant des heures et des
heures. Je vais juste essayer de passer
quelques questions à l'internet parce
que votre emploi du temps est compliqué
aujourd'hui. Euh question d'internet, le
projet de centrale nucléaire russe sur
l'eau, vous avez des choses à dire ? Euh
après dire non, j'ai pas suivi cette
histoire, je connais pas.
D'accord. Est-ce que la Russie vole
dérèglement climatique comme une
opportunité ou comme une menace ?
H non, c'est tout de même on fait partie
du de l'accord de Paris. Ouais. Ouais.
C'est c'est monsieur Trump qui l'a
quitté mais pas nous. Donc on fait
partie des forts internationales dans ce
domaine. C'est plutôt une menace.
La l'ouverture de la route du nord.
Oui, écoutez, mais l'ouverture de la
route de Nord, si elle est accompagnée
par des euh par des changements de
climat qui vont faire des déluges dans
des grandes parties de la Russie ou des
des explosions d'hydrates de carbone,
voilà, et des zones qui sont aujourd'hui
agricoles vont devenir des déserts, on
en veut pas. C'est c'est donc je pense
je pense que oui, la Russie peut
profiter un peu de ce de ce ces
changements climatiques parce queon
devient un pays un peu plus tiède queon
éit auparavant mais on ne sait pas les
conséquences. On sait pas les
conséquences. Si le golfstream cesse
d'arriver en Europe, ça aura aussi des
conséquences pour la Russie, pour
l'agriculture, pour tout parce que notre
tout le notre nord dépend du Goldstream
qui va jusqu'en Norvège et donc toutes
les les pluies, voilà tout ça, tout ce
qui vient du nord parce que les vents
atlantiques, ils dominent en Russie et
donc si si l'Atlantique devient gelé, ça
sera un autre climat en Russie aussi. Ça
ça peut devenir assez dangereux. Donc
non, on fait partie de des accords
climatiques et d'ailleurs personne nous
a soupçonné de mener à double jeu là
dans la question d'internet. Est-ce que
les journaux russes sont aussi détenus
par les milliardaires par des
milliardaires comme en France ? Est-ce
qu'il y a une concentration des des
médias
aux mains de quelques-uns ?
Non, parce que
c'est tout dans la main de l'État, c'est
ça ?
Euh non, non plus. Il y a des journaux
qui sont du diable. Oui, propriétaire.
Oui, je comprends. Non, non, c'était
surtout la télévision qui intéressait
les oligarches russes, les les grand
argent, les grandes finances russe. Il
contrôlait la première chaîne, la 4è
chaîne nationale et puis beaucoup de de
grandes chaînes de télévision
et parce qu'il voulait utiliser ces
chaînes pas tellement dans le dans début
commerciaux mais surtout dans début
politique en tant que marteau politique
pendant les élections et ainsi de suite.
Mais cette tendance a déjà passé et
aujourd'hui les grandes chaînes ou bien
oui elles appartiennent à l'État surtout
c'est la première la deuxème elle
appartient à l'état la 4e elle
appartient à Gazprom c'est enfin c'est
c'est une compagnie d'état bien que une
compagnie avec des actionnaires. Donc
c'est c'est c'est mélangé mais tout de
même c'est une compagnie d'État. La
troisème chaîne où je travaille, j'ai
mon mon programme, elle appartient à la
ville de Moscou et donc
non, c'est il y a certaines chaînes qui
sont privées. Oui, enfin une dizaine,
une dizaine mais ils sont des chaînes
surtout commerciales. Il montrent des
films, des euh des trucs l'humour, les
les céréales, comment vous appelez ça ?
Les euh comment ça s'appelle ? Quand
quand vous
Non, pas non, quand vous avez une série
de documentaires. Non, non. de films qui
qui durent pendant 140 séries. Oui, des
séries. Voilà. Oui. Oui. C'est c'est
c'est purement commercial. Et oui.
D'ailleurs, un sénateur qui a un show
télé, c'est normal ?
Euh non. Euh d'après ce que disent
certains de mes collègues en Europe,
oui, d'après les lois russes, parce que
les lois russes n'interdisent pas à un
député ou un sénateur de
euh suivre des métiers, de profer des
métiers artistiques, ce qui veut dire
être directeur de de cinéma, acteur,
professeur, euh
animateur à la télévision ou auteur d'un
programme, ce qui m' interdit, je peux
pas être directeur général d'une chaîne.
Alors parce que là c'est déjà un autre
travail. C'est un travail qui entre en
conflit avec mes positions. Mais
autrement, je suis pas le seul. Il y a
un député qui a un programme un talk
show à la première chaîne. Il y a un
autre qui a fait ça pendant 5 ans. Donc
en Russie, c'est considéré comme normal.
Bien que je sais que dans certains pays
ça ça ça soulève ça ça des questions ça
se poser des questions mais non je pense
que en Russie ça passe très bien.
Combien ça gagne un sénateur russe ?
Un sénateur russe ça gagne à peu près
dans les
je veux vous dire dans les 5000 €
net.
Non non non. Euh c'est c'est une somme
qui qui est touchée par les impôts. Donc
ça revient c'est beaucoup moins parce
que 13 % c'est payé par pour les impôts.
13 % ça va.
Oui, je dis pas que c'est beaucoup mais
tout de même c'est pas net.
Alors autre question d'internet. Que
compte faire la Russie mesure de
rétorsion sanction vis-à-vis de
l'affaire Cachogi.
Affaire Cachogi c'est quoi ?
C'est le journaliste qui s'est fait
mettre en morceaux balancer. Ah,
Cachogi.
Écoutez euh
euh
h je ne pense pas que la Russie va
dévancer les pays occidentaux en prenant
des mesures dans ce domaine. Si les pays
occidentaux commencent à
euh par exemple refuser de vendre des
armes comme le Canada euh ou euh
on va pas d'armes euh pour le moment à
l'Arabie Saoudite donc euh c'est une
question qui ne se pose pas.
[grognement]
Bon alors autre question d'internet. Que
compte faire la Russie ? Non mais ça
c'est bon. Euh euh l'OTAN et ses
mouvements militaires en Norvège
maintenant que l'article est navigable.
Point d'interrogation. L'appropriation
de cette route par la Russie est-elle
donc considérée comme un danger par
l'OTAN ?
Oui, je sais que l'OTAN est intéressé
par la dimension de
de la mer de Barans et de de ce trafic
du nord.
Je sais que il y a un programme spécial
qui a été établi par l'OTAN de renforcer
sa présence en Norvège et dans les eaux
des mers du Nord.
H oui, ça c'est c'est c'est ça fait
partie de cette confrontation
que nous avons avec l'OTAN. Comme j'ai
dit, le temps approche près de nos
frontières. On n'aime pas ça. Je ne
pense pas que ça va mener à une
confrontation militaire.
Mais bien sûr que
nous prenons des mesures contre ça. Ça
veut dire que nous sommes aussi plus
actifs dans le domaine militaire dans
les M du Nord. Mais je ne pense pas que
le temps va stopper le trafic de nos
brises glace ou de nos vaisseaux
commerciaux. Ça va pas aller jusque là.
Surtout que il y a un accord sur euh
l'Arctique
euh qui a été je pense été signé il y a
une vingtaine d'années où font partie
les États-Unis, le Canada, le Norvège,
la Russie, le Danemark
et
et c'est tout euh qui gère justement ces
questions de contrôle sur l'Arctique. Et
je dois vous dire que c'est une des
dimensions où on est assez proche euh
par exemple avec les Canadiens.
Euh on on a un dialogue avec les
Américains sur ça. Donc ça marche pas
tellement mal sur l'Actique pour le
moment. Bien sûr, il y aura toujours des
gens qui vont dire "Non, il faut
confronter les Russes aussi dans
l'Arctique. Pour le moment, c'est pas
arrivé. Il y a une tendance vers ça.
Mais je pense que tout le monde aura
intérêt à conserver ce cet accord parce
que au moins, il y a une zone, on ne se
confronte pas directement. Il faudrait
il faudrait que cet accord euh ne soit
pas euh
démonté par ceux qui voudraient
commencer une nouvelle guerre froide
partout, pas seulement en Europe, mais
aussi dans le nord.
Alors, question internet. Vladimir
Poutine a déclaré samedi que le cremelin
devrait devrait jouer un rôle de premier
plan dans le rap russe plutôt que de le
censurer. Un avis ?
Écoutez euh
vous êtes rap euh Non, mais je suis
contre la censure en principe parce que
ayant mon programme depuis 20 ans à la
télévision russe, je suis évidemment
contre la censure. Donc si monsieur
Poutine considère qu'on doit soutenir le
Russe, c'est une position que je vais
pas contester, mais je ne pense pas que
c'est une question d'importance
nationale.
Alors, question internet qui qui n'est
pas bête du tout. Euh n'est pas
incohérent de remettre en cause le
système libéral en début d'interview et
de répondre qu'il manque de croissance
quand on demande ce qu'il ne va pas en
Russie.
[soupir]
Mais le système néolibéral, c'est pas
seulement un système économique. Et puis
regardez par exemple
la Chine, c'est une économie libérale
mais avec un régime politique
communiste. Donc il y a le libéralisme
économique comme tel. Je l'ai pas
attaqué. J'ai parlé du système
néolibéral
qui préconise le contrôle de la grande
finance sur la politique nationale et
qui est à la base de l'idéologie du
globalisme.
Et là, je pense qu'il y a il y a de
grands dangers. Mais les éléments d'une
économie libérale, ben nous les avons
dans notre économie. Par exemple, euh
quel est le prélèvement d'impôts en
France sur sur les gens fortunés ? Ça
c'est ça doit être 35 % 45 % quelque
part. Ça a baissé avec Macron.
Oui, d'accord. Mais pas jusqu'à 13 %
comme chez nous. Donc, on est beaucoup
plus libéral du côté d'impôt que la
France ou que quand nous nous disons que
nous avons 13 % d'impôt sur les
salaires, les Allemands disent ça c'est
un rêve, ça c'est très libéral. Donc euh
on on n'est absolument pas contre
d'utiliser les éléments du libéralisme
dans le modèle économique, mais le
problème c'est que vous ne pouvez pas
créer des économies euh
en tant que bulle financière qui explose
à un certain moment et puis tout le
monde est impliqué. Donc c'est ça que
j'avais envie. On on parle vous parlez
de bul financière qui éclate.
On voit souvent des nouvelles passer
comme quoi la Russie renforce son stock
d'or physique.
Oui.
Depuis un certain nombre d'années
d'ailleurs.
C'est une assurance pour la prochaine
crise financière. C'est une façon de se
dédolariser.
Oui.
On se méfie du dollar. On se méfie du
dollar pour des raisons évidentes parce
que les Américains
ne se gênent plus. Euh je veux dire que
les sanctions euh qu'il utilise
aujourd'hui et ces sanctions sont
utilisées pas seulement contre la Russie
mais c'est contre l'Iran, déjà contre la
Chine, il menace l'Inde de sanction, il
menace la Turquie de sanction.
D'ailleurs, la Turquie aussi achète de
l'or parce que le dollar est devenu une
menace. Si vous êtes trop étroitement
lié au système financier américain, vous
pouvez en souffrir. À un certain moment,
ils vont vous dire "Hop, c'est terminé."
Et là vous vous si si vous avez une
dépendance excessive du dollar, ça peut
vous faire des problèmes. Donc un nombre
de pays qui voit que l'Amérique en
essayant de conserver son hégémonie
commence à utiliser des leviers
financiers, des sanctions financières
pour vous faire changer de politique.
Ces pays-là commencent à se dédolariser,
commencent à étudier les moyens de moins
dépendre du dollar et du système
financier américain. La cryptomonnaie,
ça vous parle ?
On en parle beaucoup en Russie. Il y a
des gens qui investissent, c'est à la
mode.
Euh, deux dernières questions. Quel
politicien français a sa préférence ?
Vous avez une préférence dans un un de
nos politiques ?
En France, de Gaul,
évidemment. Oui, parce que c'était
quelqu'un qui est allé
dire merde aux Américains.
Non, non. Pour moi, de Gaulle, c'est
quelqu'un
qui a conservé
une idée de la France quand la France
était détruite.
Je me rappelais toujours ses paroles
quand il a dit euh qu'il a prononcé
quand Churchill a déclaré que la
Grande-Bretagne entre dans la phase
active de la guerre contre contre
Hitler.
De était le seul français présent
pendant cette cérémonie et il a dit
"Monsieur le premier ministre, je
voulais que vous sachiez que la France
sera toujours avec vous même si Just
était son seul porte-dedrapeau."
Pas mal, pas mal.
Le le Donc, on arrive à la fin. Trois
trois livres à conseiller
à nos auditeurs, à notre communauté.
Ah là c'est une question compliquée ça
parce que il faut choisir. Oui. Et vous
voulez dire livre contemporain ou
vous avez le choix ?
J'ai le choix. On peut passer de Sunzu à
Claus jusqu'à
Écoutez, je vais vous nommer les livres
qui ont produit une certaine impression
sur moi que j'ai lu [gémissement] enfin
dans ces
dernières années.
Un de ces livres c'est un livre que qui
je pense très contesté en France c'est
soumission de Michel Welbec.
Je pense que c'est un livre très
intelligent.
Euh j'ai aussi
lu un livre sur la conférence de Munich
qui c'est la conférence de 1938
quand les grandes démocraties
européennes sont mis d'accord avec
monsieur Hitler Mussolini pour diviser
la Tchoslovaquie.
C'est un livre qui s'appelle Munich
écrit par
Richard Haris. C'est un Richard Harris,
un écrivain britannique assez connu.
Euh c'est le deuxè livre et le 3è livre,
je vais vous
et écoutez voilà, je vais vous parler
d'un livre
qui a été écrit par ma femme, qui n'a
pas encore paru en France mais que
j'espère va paraître en France en 2019.
C'est un livre sur les aventures d'une
jeune étudiante russe dans les années
90. C'est année d'un capitalisme
criminel sans sans bride et sans limite.
Euh c'est un thriller, un
film un roman noir un peu dans la
tradition française policière
mais avec une fin assez assez heureuse.
Et pour le moment, elle s'appelle la
déesse de la victoire parce que le
personnage principal du livre, elle
s'appelle Nika. Et la nika de Samotraki
si vous la nika avec les ailes là que
vous avez où l'ouvre, c'est la déesse de
la victoire. C'est le symbole de la
victoire et donc c'est le nom russe du
livre, la déesse de la victoire.
Peut-être il va être changé dans
l'édition française. Et voilà, c'est un
livre que j'ai beaucoup aimé. C'est le
livre de ma femme.
C'était Robert Haris sorti en Haris.
D'accord.
Et donc dernière question, c'est pas une
question, c'est laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations, une bouteille à
la mer, quelque chose d'impérissable.
Écoutez, mais vous deviez me prévenir
que vous avez posé des questions qui
nécessitent beaucoup mais voyez ces
questions là, elles nécessitent beaucoup
de réflexion parce que il y a une
certaine responsabilité.
Alors c bouteilles à la mer,
non une bouteille à la mer.
Une bouteille à la mer au génération
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Génération future.
Essayez de limiter votre bêtise pour
conserver la terre.
Alex Pouchkov, merci. On vous remercie
de vous être exprimé en français d'un
français très ciselé et on vous souhaite
une excellente journée. Merci.
Merci. Merci à vous. Au revoir.